[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est quoi vous aurez vous posé à moi va
proposer c'est tout c'est pas pareil
alors je vais vous dire que philippe
genevois dès qu'un truc où il faut faire
mieux on m'appelle monde pareil parce
que je riais philippe vous êtes très
très populaire et je pense que les
directeurs de chaîne les producteurs
savent qu'avec philippe candeloro vous
allez faire le spectacle que vous êtes
très connu que vous que vous êtes un bon
client donc plein de retenue quoi et en
or mais j'ai dit non alors j'ai dit non
parce qu'il y avait énormément oui comme
je dis toujours ma chaque prime mérite
salaire et comment on demain on me
demandait on me demandait de neuf
semaines de 10 dt je travaillais quatre
jours par semaine et bon comme je
travaille encore beaucoup
j'ai la chance de pouvoir la suivre
encore bien gagner ma vie avec ça quand
on me demande neuf semaines de
disponibilité
je demande la compensation et ils sont
six et pas été capables de s'aligner ses
propos mais vous proposer combien faut
nous aident à dire bien sûr gagner on
vous demande combien il vous proposer ça
va c'est presque pareil moi je moi je
peux vous dire qu'on me proposait des
buts au départ eh ben